(ambient music)
- There's more to sight
than just being able to see the crowd.
You can definitely feel the atmosphere.
There's a vibe in the air,
there's the energy in the air,
there's a sound.
It's amazing to hear the fans,
especially when we run outta the tunnel.
(exciting music)
I'm Jake Olson; I'm the long snapper
of the University of
Southern California Trojans.
I'm completely blind, I have no eyes.
I went in to play football
with the mentality
that I had nothing to lose.
Long snapping is an art.
You definitely have the mechanics,
but a lot of it is just feel.
Feeling that ball come off
your fingertips in a spiral,
how hard you're throwing it, you know,
where you're releasing it,
just kinda getting that velocity,
and that accuracy.
Life's unfair, football's unfair,
but at the same time,
it's up to you of how far
you wanna take yourself.
When I was eight months
old, I was diagnosed
with a rare form of eye
cancer called retinoblastoma.
When the doctor found my cancer,
it was completely taking over my left eye,
so they almost immediately
removed my left eye.
From there on, you know, just a cycle of,
you know, the cancer coming back,
then we fight it with treatments.
Doctors finally said, listen,
we've pretty much exhausted
all our treatment options.
The safer option is just, you
know, the removal of the eye.
Growing up in the 2000s where
Coach Carroll was so dominant
with USC, it was hard not to be a USC fan.
I always loved football.
I continued to play flag
football my eighth grade year,
after losing my sight.
It was not anything
close to tackle football.
As I entered high school, I
decided not to play football
for my freshman and sophomore year.
It really was something that
I didn't think I could do.
But eventually, my love
for the game really overcame any doubts,
and I learned how to be an asset.
I just love the camaraderie of football;
I love being part of the team’
love putting on, you know, just the pads
and the jersey and stuff,
and being part of the team was enough
just to get me to try.
(smooth electronic music)